hallo ihr lieben heute mal sehr sehr
ungewohnt und vor allem im hochformat
ihr könnt hier unten auf dieses fest
nicht wirklich aussieht könnte drauf
klicken und dann vergrößert sich der
bildschirm und ihr seht alles ist die
kleine ankündigung und zwar ist er also
zumindest wenn ihr uns auf social media
verfolgt habt insbesondere auf instagram
das letzten wochen schon sehr
anstrengend war vor allem im hinblick
auf mein kochbuch aber dazu geht es noch
ein ausführliches video geben und ich
habe wirklich die letzten wochen und
monate nur fürs kochbuch quasi
experimentiert fotografiert getippt
geschrieben der haben so stell ich mir
immer zur seite
und gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich
auch euch mit tollen rezepten hier auf
youtube versorgt jetzt ist es so dass in
guten 2 wochen der fastenmonat ramadan
startet und ihr wisst ja dass ich seit
ich den karl gründet habe schon immer
meine ramadan reihe gemacht hat das ist
so mein baby weil da steckt immer so die
meiste zeit reden ganz viel mühe ganz
viel liebe und egal ob wir jetzt muslime
seit oder einer anderen religion
angehört das ist vollkommen egal bei der
reihe
denn es geht darum dass ich euch
besonders viele und sehr sehr leckere
authentische orientalische rezepte
präsentiert und davids daneben mehr
videos geben als sonst ein ganz monat
lang und das braucht halt viel
vorbereitungszeit wir wollen einen teil
der noch vorträgen und einen teil aber
auch während des ramadans dreht und wir
nehmen euch da ja auch immer ganz
transparenten wird vor allem auf
instagram daher jetzt der aufruf folgt
mir unbedingt auf instagram wenn ihr es
noch nicht tut ja auch dem hammer wenn
ich mal nicht schaffe stories zu machen
und dann macht er das und haben sie hat
ja mittlerweile auch einen blog kanal
gestartet wo er dann noch zeigt was
passiert darüber ob sind in den kulissen
und die werde ich auch noch mal hier
unten verlinkten ansonsten wollt ihr
euch sogar gerne diese kleine pause
jetzt ankündigen
in den nächsten ein bis zwei wochen wird
es keine videos geben damit wir uns eben
voll und ganz auf den videodreh
konzentrieren können ich finde es halt
auch immer mega höflich bescheid zu
geben und ich bin auch mal undankbar
wenn man dann nicht bescheid gibt und
einfach weg ist ja und das wollte ich
euch halt nur mitteilen
jetzt hoffe ich auch mal den hammer der
fehlt mir hier so ein bisschen hans a
[Musik]
das ist der plan hinter jetzt du bist
das catchen von cookies ich bin glaube
ich ja gerade baum ja auf jeden fall
leute wir bereit etwas richtig cooles
freude machen wir dann alle drei teile
oder alle zwei tage aber das ist drei
mal die woche handeln ist doch bei
[Musik]
also leute bei merck die wochen etwas
abstand noch ein bisschen gebraucht
business app
und genau hier haben auf jeden fall
richtig cooles schon immer gehabt und
das wichtigste ist passend zum drama da
kommt ja das kopftuch noch aufpassen
das kochbuch das konnte er jetzt schon
vorbestellen könnt das auch immer noch
vorbestellen und dann geht es dann
pünktlich quasi zu beginn des ramadan
auch raus also den linken dann lasse ich
mich auch hier und wir uns überlegt ich
werde auch youtube shorts hochladen das
sind kurzvideos einfach so weil das auch
coole videos auch sind das ersetzt
natürlich nicht meine rezept videos aber
es ist wie gesagt eigentlich mit pause
aber ich möchte halt trotzdem hier und
da ein bisschen was von mir hochland ich
sage ist nächste woche sonst meinen blog
den ich folgte dann letzte woche
okay gut ich konnte ich auch fest wenn
du glaubst du ich guck dir dann auch mal
und co ich wollte eva sah ich das
vergessen aber egal leute pause pause
bzw einheit pause
wir sehen uns in alter frische während
da kann man dann genieße das wetter
bleibt gesund
[Musik]